Italia es el único país, junto a Grecia,
que es más pobre ahora que cuando entró
en el Euro. Tal cual como lo oís. Si seguís
VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo ya sabéis
que, dentro del equipo que hacemos posible
este canal, yo soy el más europeísta de
todos. Pero en este caso, las cifras son claras:
Italia ha salido perdiendo con la Unión Europea.
Hablamos de la segunda potencia industrial
de Europa, sólo por detrás de Alemania.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en los años
90, los italianos eran más ricos que los
británicos o los franceses. Y los que tengáis
mi edad o seáis más mayores, recordaréis
a Rafaella Carrá, Laura Pausini o los juguetes
de...
Italia ha sido una de las mayores potencias
del planeta. Y todo esto a pesar de su gobierno
y sus políticos. Porque sí, amigos de VisualPolitik,
la historia política de este país es...
¿Cómo decirlo? A su lado, Juego de Tronos
parece La Casa de la Pradera. Para que os
hagáis una idea, los italianos tienen a la
mafia siciliana, la camorra napolitana, la
n´drangretta calabresa y otras tantas bandas
de crimen organizado. Y todas ellas tienen,
todavía hoy, conexiones políticas al más
alto nivel
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de mafia!
Durante la Guerra Fría, el gobierno italiano
llegó a financiar a grupos terroristas de
extrema derecha que organizaron los atentados
más sangrientos del país ¿Y la extrema
izquierda? Pues tampoco se quedó atrás.
Las brigadas rojas secuestraron y asesinaron
a nada menos que un primer ministro. Es más,
si tenéis curiosidad y os gusta el morbo,
os recomiendo que busquéis información sobre
la logia Propaganda Due. O que veáis la película
Il Divo, de Paolo Sorrentino. Descubriréis
un país fascinante y donde la política es
de todo menos aburrida.
Y os preguntaréis
¿Pero qué está pasando ahora en Italia?
¿Siguen las cosas tan movidas como en los
años 70 y 80? Pues
podéis juzgar por vosotros mismos. En sólo
10 años, Italia ha tenido 6 primeros ministros
distintos. 6. En sólo 10 años. En otras
palabras, que seguir el día a día de la
política italiana es misión imposible.
Y por eso, en este vídeo no vamos a centrarnos
ni en las elecciones Italianas que se han
celebrado recientemente ni en los escarceos
de Berlusconi. Porque la pregunta más interesante
es ¿Cómo es posible que un país con semejante
sistema político pudiera llegar a ser tan
rico? ¿Y qué pasó después para que hayan
llegado a tener 2 décadas sin crecimiento
económico? Hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver a conocer a “el bueno,
el feo y el malo” de la historia política italiana.
GIULIO ANDREOTTI ES
“EL BUENO”
En los años 40, Italia era el país con el
Partido Comunista más grande de toda Europa
Occidental. Tenían más de 1.300.000 afiliados,
lo que significa que, en cualquier momento,
podían ganar unas elecciones. Como os podéis
imaginar, en plena Guerra Fría, EEUU estaba
dispuesto a hacer cualquier cosa para evitarlo
¿Recordáis el PLAN MARSHALL? Si sois veteranos
seguidores de VisualPolitik, ya sabéis que
el Tío Sam mandó toneladas de dinero a Europa
para que se reconstruyera tras la II Guerra
Mundial.
En el caso de Italia, este dinero
no sólo servía para ayudar al país sino
también para ayudar al único partido que
podía hacer frente a los comunistas. Y ese
partido era la DEMOCRACIA CRISTIANA.
“¡Madre, salva a tus hijos del bolchevismo!
Vota Democracia cristiana!”
En los siguientes 50 años, Italia tuvo hasta
30 primeros gobiernos distintos. Tal cual
como lo oís. Eso significa que, la edad media
de un primer ministro italiano era de poco
más de un año y medio. Pero todos ellos
tenían una cosa en común: prácticamente
todos pertenecían a la Democracia Cristiana.
Y si hay una persona que destaca en esos años
es este señor que veis en la pantalla: Giulio
Andreotti.
Un hombre que llegó a ser
Primer Ministro no una ni dos ni tres sino
SIETE VECES! Durante décadas, Andreotti era
algo así como el padrino de la política
italiana. Prácticamente, cualquiera que quisiera
llegar a algo en la clase dirigente de este
país, necesitaba su bendición.
“El poder desgasta a aquellos que no lo
tienen” —Giulio Andreotti
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero qué defendía la
Democracia Cristiana Italiana, exactamente?
Pues
básicamente era un cóctail ideológico que
combinaba TODO lo que no fuera comunismo.
Eso incluía pactos ocultos con la Cosa Nostra
siciliana, la Camorra Napolitana y, presuntamente,
grupos terroristas de extrema derecha que
asolaron el país durante los años 80. Pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Lo cierto es que, tanto la Democracia Cristiana como
los gobiernos de Andreotti necesitaban asegurarse
el apoyo popular. Las elecciones no se ganan
solas. Y para eso ¿Qué mejor que dar trabajos
bien pagados?
Italia tiene más de 3 millones
y medio de funcionarios y están entre los
mejores pagados del mundo.
Es más, desde
los tiempos de Andreotti hasta nuestros días,
Italia es famoso por dos cosas: juzgados que
no funcionan y papeleos interminables. Para
que os hagáis una idea, vamos a imaginar
que tenemos una empresa que vende maquinaria
de construcción y tenemos un cliente que
no nos quiere pagar lo que nos debe. Lo lógico
es que lo denunciemos en un tribunal ¿Verdad?
Pues bien, este proceso en un país como Francia
nos llevaría una media de 2 meses y medio.
En Italia tendríamos que esperar más de
3 años para que nos resolvieran nuestro problema.
Como os podéis imaginar, este no es ni era
el mejor clima para los negocios. Sin embargo
¿No hemos dicho que Italia llegó a ser uno
de los países más prósperos de Europa?
¿Cómo es posible que Italia tuviera empresas
tan competitivas? Pues, mis queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik, la respuesta está en la
Lira Italiana.
Tal cual como lo oís. Al tener su propia
moneda, el Banco Central Italiano podía devaluar
la divisa cada vez que necesitaba poner su
economía en esteroides.
Y os preguntaréis ¿No se supone que eso
es lo contrario que hay que hacer? Por ejemplo,
en este otro vídeo os contábamos que Alemania
se hizo rica, en parte, gracias a tener una
divisa fuerte como era el marco alemán.
Sin embargo, ahora os estoy diciendo lo contrario
¿Cómo es esto posible? ¿Cómo es posible
que Italia creciera tanto pese a las devaluaciones,
la corrupción y la burocracia?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
ROCCO SIGFREDDI ES “EL FEO”
Los millenials que veáis este vídeo no tendréis
ni idea de lo que estoy hablando. Pero antes,
mucho antes de que Nacho Vidal conquistara
las pantallas de vuestros ordenadores, Rocco
Sigfreddi era conocido en todo el mundo como
“el semental italiano”. Con más de 1700
películas a sus espaldas, se convirtió en
el rey de los Videoclubs.
Y, sin darse cuenta,
también en todo un símbolo de la
vigorosa economía italiana.
Durante los años 80 y 90, Italia inundaba
los mercados mundiales con productos baratos.
Era algo así como la China del siglo XX.
SI algo funcionaba en otro país, acto seguido
aparecía una empresa italiana que hacía
lo mismo pero
¡Más barato!
Ejemplo: el cine del Oeste. Las películas
de John Wayne tenían muchísimo éxito en
EEUU. Así que en Italia no tardaron en salir
cientos de productoras de cine que hacían
más de lo mismo pero más barato y en cantidades
industriales.
Así surgió el “spaghetti
western”. Y lo mismo ocurrió con todo lo
demás. Cuando Donna Summer hacía bailar
al mundo entero con sus melodías pegadizas,
los italianos contraatacaban con SABRINA,
que hacía lo mismo pero más barato y más
explícito
¿Y qué me decís del cine de
animación? A la vez que DISNEY estrenaba
ALADDIN en las salas de cine, la versión
barata producida en Italia ya estaba disponible
en todos los videoclubs.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de cultura barata! En general, toda
la industria italiana era barata. O, como
se diría en lenguaje académico, “de bajo
valor añadido”. Italia era especialista
en producir ropa, muebles y objetos de plástico.
Si os comprabais un muñeco de juguete en
los años 90, es muy posible que tuviera la
etiqueta de MADE IN ITALY. Ahora bien, si
os comprabais un equipo de música, seguramente
dijera “MADE IN JAPAN” o “MADE IN GERMANY”
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué? ¿Por qué
los Italianos vivían de vender baratijas
en el extranjero? Pues
fijaros en esta gráfica. Aquí se puede ver
el valor de la LIRA ITALIANA frente al MARCO
ALEMÁN. Como veis, durante los 80 y 90, la
lira estuvo devaluándose continuamente.
En
el año 1980, te daban unas 450 liras por
un marco alemán. 15 años más tarde, te
daban 1300 liras ¿Y esto qué significa?
Pues que innovar era mucho más caro para
las empresas italianas. Por ejemplo, imaginad
que tenemos una productora de cine en Italia,
en los años 80, y queremos producir una superproducción
estilo “Star Wars”, con efectos especiales
de última generación. Para eso, necesitaremos
comprar ese software de animación que se
vende en Japón o esas cámaras especiales
para grabar escenas de acción que se fabrican
en Estados Unidos. Pero, si nuestra moneda
vale menos cada día, esas cosas que se hacen
en el extranjero nos costarán cada vez más
dinero. A esto hay que sumarle el hecho de
que, para paso que queremos dar, necesitamos
esperar meses para conseguir permisos y licencias del gobierno.
Sin embargo, imaginad que en lugar de producir
Star Wars, rodamos una película con Rocco
Siffredi. Sólo necesitamos un par de cámaras
y una habitación con una cama. Y, al tener
una divisa debil, podemos llegar al mercado
internacional y vender nuestra producción
por un precio mucho más barato que la competencia.
¿Se entiende bien? Pues
fijaos en la gráfica porque con este esquema,
la economía italiana empezó a crecer a un
ritmo
roccosiffrediano
Habéis visto bien
en los años 90 Italia llegó a ser más rica,
en renta per cápita, que Francia o Reino
Unido. En estos años, nacieron miles de
pequeñas empresas ¡Pero no se parecían
en nada a las de Alemania! Veréis, las Mittlestands
alemanas eran empresas de entre 50 y 200 trabajadores,
que tenían suficiente economía de escala
como para invertir en innovación.
En el caso
de Italia, sus empresas son mucho más pequeñas
y mucho más tradicionales y, en la mayor
parte de los casos, mucho más ilegales.
Cuando Italia empezó a contabilizar su economía
sumergida, que supone la quinta parte de su
PIB, la economía creció un 18% de la
noche a la mañana.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero, para qué querían
innovar los italianos si, con este modelo,
les iba fenomenal? Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
SILVIO BERLUSCONI ES “EL MALO”
Por fin llegamos al siglo XXI. La Democracia
Cristiana ya es historia y el nuevo y flamante
líder de la derecha italiana es este hombre
que veis aquí que no necesita presentación
el señor Silvio Berlusconi.
“Tengo poco pelo porque mi cerebro es tan
grande que aparta todo lo demás” —Silvio Berlusconi.
En otro vídeo nos centraremos más en la
trayectoria de Berlusconi. Pero lo cierto
es que el año 2002 no era el mejor momento
para ser el presidente de Italia. Y os preguntaréis
¿Por qué? Pues porque 2002 es el año en
el que Italia abandonó la LIRA ITALIANA y
entró en el EURO ¿Y cuál es la principal
característica del EURO?
Pues que no lo controla
el gobierno de ningún país. Los Euros los
emite el Banco Central Europeo, que está
formado por representantes de varios países.
Para un país adicto a las devaluaciones,
esto es todo un problema.
¡Pero la cosa no termina aquí! ¿Recordáis
que otra cosa ocurrió a principios del siglo
XXI? ¡Dejadme que os refresque la memoria!
China, por fín, entra en la Organización
Mundial del Comercio
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué tiene que ver lo
que pasa en China con la economía Italiana?
Pues mucho. Porque el hecho de que China entrara
en la Organización Mundial del Comercio era
todo un síntoma de algo más gordo.
Asia
estaba inundando los mercados internacionales.
Porque no sólo hablamos de China. También
otros países como Bangladesh o Tailandia
ya estaban empezando a vender sus productos
¿Y qué es lo que se fabricaba en Asia por
aquel entonces? ¡Exacto! ¡Cosas baratas!
¡Lo mismo que fabricaban los italianos!
¡Pero aún más barato!
Por aquellos años, Alemania estaba a años
luz de Asia en lo que a tecnología se refiere.
Así que sus productos seguían siendo competitivos,
con o sin la competencia china. Mientras tanto,
Italia ya no podía utilizar el viejo truco
de devaluar porque a, estaban en el euro y
b, aunque pudieran hacerlo, no servía de
nada contra los sueldos bajos de los países
asiáticos.
Por ejemplo, una de las empresas más emblemáticas
de Italia es FIAT.
En 1990 llegaron a vender
más de 1.300.000 coches en Europa. Hoy a
duras penas superan los 700.000. Y a duras
penas han sido capaces de vender en otros
mercados. Otras marcas como BMW no sólo mantienen
sus mercados tradicionales sino que están
creciendo una barbaridad en China y otros
países emergentes.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la cosa no
termina aquí! ¿Recordáis que Italia tenía
un estado enorme con más de 3 millones de
funcionarios? Pues
¡Eso sigue estando ahí! ¡Y hay que pagarlo!
En otras palabras, que mientras la economía
Italiana cae en picado y estado recauda menos
impuestos, los gastos se mantienen.
¿Y esto qué significa? Pues que Italia es
el cuarto país más endeudado del mundo.
Su deuda pública supera el 130% de su Producto
Interior Bruto. Y eso, mis queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik, es una auténtica barbaridad
Italia es el siguiente gran problema de Europa
Así que ahora la pregunta es
¿Debería Italia abandonar el Euro para poder
volver a esa economía basada en baratijas?
¿O tal vez deberían imitar el modelo alemán
y permitir que sus empresas puedan innovar?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
¿Y qué decís? ¿Qué no conocéis el modelo
económico alemán? ¡Hombre por favor! Pues
haced click aquí y podréis ver el vídeo
donde os contamos por qué Alemania exporta
más, incluso, que China.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE,
compartidlo con vuestros amigos y nos vemos
en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.